old stearns round for walking
well this dairy we can mindfulness
location fermín timoteo Minas if that
version was gel because of soil in the
future perfect provider conditions appear
[Music]
I am timoteo Minas and I grow
volcanic coffee the idea was born for me from a
dream of  to have a coffee plant one day
and to be able to consume my own
coffee 28 years ago I started settling and the first
100 plants
[Music]
now we are on a piece of land called
Cerro de Corona we are on the slopes
of the Agua Volcano I am there from where
I have my land in recent years the
eruption has been a little more frequent
every 15 minutes it is erupting
for five minutes it brings what is
sulfur which is a nutrient it is a
nutrient for the plant and it has helped us a
lot
timoteo it is a form of extinction
oxidized red and special coffee chips
taste that it is a high altitude coffee so
what helps with the high altitude since the
coffee has more acidity in those that are strong in
acidity  and its fruit flavors that
always exist there so that
allows us to have a better quality of coffee
[Music]
first it has a part to excuse a
part where we remove the shell
from the fruit coffee
[Music]
then the seed we attach these
coffee seeds goes  to a
fermentation tank for a process of 25 hours
[Music]
and after its fermentation time
the coffee is washed in three different waters
and after washing it is placed on the patio it
takes a maximum of eight
days for it to be in  the cement patio
how old is 55 quintals of gold coffee
[Music]
timoteo special on
spring scale vince chase
the name is gerson or am i a
roaster barista and we have
a coffee shop in antigua guatemala
[music]
we are located in one of the
most  acquaintances from guatemala
here we can classify it as almost a
coffee mecca you can find
coffee shops or cafes in almost every corner
we also buy coffee once
a year with don tim  Oteo Minas Don Timo
has one of the best
natural process coffees that we have tasted
[Music]
when I came cofepris Tierra is particular and Bernard de Socios
especially
Timothy and I am grateful for that for
that experience for that work that
I am doing and the opportunities that
coffee has given
me meeting people who own
coffee shops millions of coffee from the coffee chain
and that has led me to have
good experiences also through
my cultivation
[Music]
you